welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike comer and
today we have a very special
presentation as we actually have a
victim from the audience that has
submitted some games
all right so we'll be going over a
beginner's games and hopefully at home
you can follow along see what this
gentleman is doing right see what he's
doing wrong see if there's any
similarities between your game and his
game and see how you can improve on that
okay so in this game the Bebe's as we'll
call him has the white pieces he starts
off d4 okay a very common move between
efore and d4 he chooses the Queen's pawn
there's nothing wrong with that even I
think I'm coming around to playing the
the Queen's pawn opening as well all
right so now black counters the most
common way with d5 pawn to pawn
basically what what this does is it
prevents white from playing his pawn out
to e4 basically if you're playing d4
eventually you want to get efore in and
black knows that so now he knows if I
play d5 I'm gonna stop
efore so white plays the move c4 you'll
see this a lot the Queen's Gambit okay
so now if blacks like oh look at this
free pawn excellent okay now white can
just go ahead and get he for in okay and
now he'll he's got everything he wants
see see how much of the center of the
board he's controlling and now this
bishop is eyeing this pawn okay so
that's why when you're play black in
this position we don't want to take this
a very good move to play is c6 and that
way
this pawn takes this pawn we can just
take back and now we've successfully uh
are still preventing got control of this
e4 square over here alright a move we
want to stay away from as Black is the
dreaded East six move because remember
that blacks in our bishops remember we
want to keep all our pieces as mobile as
possible okay so in this position
c6 would be good black chooses to play
Knight to f6 okay so now white could
choose to go into the Grunfeld
okay takes Knight takes and now look at
what move we have now e4 okay pretty
good pretty good for for white okay
unfortunately in this position he
decides not to trade and just calmly
develops Knight to f3 okay so now black
plays the move east six remember weak
move now our Bishop is stuck and white
didn't do anything spectacular to make
this uh this bishop be stuck right he
voluntarily just cut off the connection
between his Bishop and moving out on
this diagonal okay so so we want to not
do that when we play our chess games and
so so now unfortunately white kind of
sees why he just played east six so now
when white plays III what did he just do
you've blocked in the bishop so before
we go ahead and play e3 we can play our
Bishop here I in the c7 square or do you
play Bishop to g5 and now we're pinning
the night
okay so we don't want to just just make
weaknesses unless we're forced to unless
unless oh man it's the last thing in the
world we can do I know he wants to get
this Bishop out and I mean that helps
him get this [ __ ] about but at the
expense of this guy
all right so III was played
unfortunately and black counters with c5
here okay so now we always want to
analyze what happens when we capture but
if we capture here we're trading one of
our center pawns for a ring pawn and by
trading we're actually helping black out
because now he's got his his Bishop
developed here another thing we want to
look at is if we captured this way all
right
notice in this position that if we trade
this pun for this pawn we think while we
train one of our pawns on the fourth
rank for one of his on the fifth bank
but not really because he's going to
take like this okay and look at what
that does we're really trading this pawn
for his weak pawn up here okay so you
always want to be aware of what you're
actually trading for and remember if we
trade this pawn for this pawn okay we
let his bishop free okay so so our man
the beads
I guess he looked at all this and so he
decides he's not gonna trade he played
III to get his Bishop out to d3 so
that's that's what he plays okay so now
he decides all right I played this to
take so I'm gonna take and now he's like
that's great because now his opponent
trades and so now we can take with our
pawn and that lets our bishop become
free so you're always like a Grandmaster
once told me never trade anything
because when you trade your opponent
then takes back and that debt either
lets him develop a piece like the bishop
it puts his piece on that on that us on
that square in contention so we still is
kind of controlling that square where
you just took so so you really want to
watch out when you trade you want to get
some kind of advantage where you just
don't want to trade the trade because
you're actually helping your opponent
get to get to a better square possibly
all right and so now he takes again and
Bishop takes c4 so now if you look at
this position it is true that with all
the trades black has left white with an
isolated pawn and isolated pawn
basically means he's got no pawns right
by a side that can protect him he's
isolated so when you're isolated upon
you're going to be weaker because one of
the major pieces or minor pieces the
knight or the bishop will have to
protect him if he's under attack all
right hopefully he can just move but but
now black's bishop is still bad and he's
only got one piece develop so he's gonna
try to fix that Knight to c3 our Knight
to c6 excuse me so now he's got two
players attacking you always want to ask
yourself why did he play that move and
just don't dismiss it all you just play
just wanted to develop it no he's going
to attack but luckily he's got two
attackers and we have two defenders so
as long as we have an as many defenders
as he has attackers we're safe alright
so so we don't have to worry about that
so we castle so now white is safe in
this castle this is a really nice castle
for white you can't get checked he's got
this Knight over here protecting them to
black really has no attack so this is a
really really safe castle and if you can
get a safe castle you're gonna be doing
very well because you don't have to
worry about checks or nothing
all right castle so so now black
he wants to get castle - so Bishop to e7
kind of passive a move I would not
recommend it Bishop to b4 you don't want
to be going into your opponent's
territory when you don't have any
targets
I would PI play Bishop the d6 here
because now look we're eyeing a square
in his castle okay and then maybe we can
get you know our Queen and Bishop
working in a battery and possibly can do
some harm to him okay all right that's
just some ideas okay but Bishop e7 a
little passive I mean all you're doing
is protecting the night all right so now
white just develop some more Knight to
c3 excuse me okay so Knight c3 so now
black gets castled and safe and so now
we got white CIS his moves Bishop f4
active okay now you're controlling this
diagonal all right
so now a little late Bishop d6 the
counter
so if black was playing better you know
he would have control of this and and
this Bishop would never have even had
the chance to go here all right so
Bishop the d6
okay so unfortunately here our Bishop is
being attacked so we need to see that
but it looks like nobody really sees
that unfortunately okay so Queen to e2
so so two things so remember if we were
asking ourselves after every move why
did he make that move Bishop f4 okay
you would say oh wow he's contesting our
bishop another thing you always want to
look for captures and checks
before every move now bishops Queens and
rooks are really easy to see what
they're capturing because it's really
simple they can only take stuff that's
on their own line right like if this if
it's not on this line or this line for
the bishop you can't take anything okay
with the rook it's the same thing if
it's not on you know the first rank or
the F file he's not gonna be able to
take it
Queen's a little bit harder because
she's got a lot of diagonals but it's
same thing if if it's not on the same
diagonal line not on the same rank not
on the same file the queen is not gonna
take it so if you just look and all that
you can't ever be surprised like oh I
just lost my queen the rook came down
and took it because hey if the rook and
the Queen aren't on the same line you
don't have to worry about it because
there's no way that rook can ever take
that Queen unless they're lined up on
the same line all right so that's what
you want to be looking for is like
what's on the same line obviously
Knights are trickier they jump from dark
Square to a light square so if they
don't really work in the same straight
line pad but if it's Knights are a dark
square if your piece is internal light
square guess what it's not going to get
captured because it can only jump to
light squares but that's something you
really want to look for in games okay so
Queen to e2 and unfortunately he didn't
see that you know why he played Bishop
d6 was a take I guess he looked at your
I don't know why he didn't take that and
in black played a6 and now you bring
this rook to e1 so so when you're when
you're deciding rich rook to bring to a
square try to think ahead in the game
and it's like in this game you'd ask
yourself am I ever going to move any of
this stuff
Metapod
off the F file right now it would be
really difficult to move this pawn off
the F file so so really he really can't
can't do much or on this F file and then
you see that this C file is uh is open
right this D file I might want to get a
brook behind the pawn you know to
protect this isolated pawn so if you
really want to put a rook on e one you
say well my work on that the a file he
might go to either the C file or the D
file so I want to put this rook look
there
so now if you put this work over here
guess what now this rook can't move your
boxing yourself in so so a big part in
chess that's what actually all these
pieces the Queen the bishop everybody
except for the King there number like
the bishops were three the work is worth
five their number is based on how mobile
they are like ebooks are worth five
points basically that's just
he's only really worth that five if
you're getting him mobile and he's doing
a lot of good stuff like right now this
rook really doesn't look like a
five-point piece does he all he's doing
is protecting the pawn and protecting
the other rook he looks like maybe a
one-point piece at the most at the
moment okay but if this rook was here
and then you guess rook got over here
then you'd be doing a little bit better
so so always ask yourself because that
comes up a lot in games always ask
yourself which rook should I go try to
think ahead well where do you want the
other rope to be okay so so when you
play real care black finally figures out
hey up I can take this bishop okay but
just be just because you're down three
points though you don't really need to
panic because you know you're playing
another amateur and you can always make
a comeback possibly all right so so
white plays the move d5 trying to get
rid of his isolated pawn
so black happily takes because now his
bishop gets freed up so Knight takes d5
and now now black makes a serious
mistake and this is something I just
learned the other day so you may have
you been playing chess for fifteen
twenty years thirty years you can always
learn stuff if you're trying to seek out
knowledge okay look white pretty much
controls this square but black goes
heads and put something on that square
anyhow so if your opponent has control
of a key square in a position guess what
hey don't put a piece on there okay
there are else because it's fine to be
take it so now white sees the
combination to win the game
can you are you or you so so this is a
big blunder white has two players
controlling a eight so black plays rook
to e8 see how this rook attacks EI t'
through an x-ray it's called like he
sees through the queen and he's
attacking here okay so so how many
protectors of EI t' does black currently
have to the knight and the queen there's
a really cool tactic and chest called
removing the guard it's probably the
best so if you could remove one of those
guards guess what you're gonna get this
rook for for free right okay
so so is there any way we could remove
the queen or the knight from protecting
this rook so so unfortunately this this
bishop as LightSquared can't can't go to
a5 and of course you weep
even if we could play that remember here
you can just come down and take our
queen and then we would take our queen
but we do have one better move here
Knight takes Knight Shaq
all right so now this guy gone removed
and so if black took back smart you take
back like this and then what move could
we do then yes even though we're taking
a queen here we're gonna play Queen
takes rook check Queen takes Queen rook
takes check King moves and then we won
our piece back okay okay so he's got one
two three four pieces and we have one
two three four okay and now he's got
these double pawns isolate upon double
punch and we're doing pretty well here
unfortunately in the game yeah you
decided to that he didn't want those
double pawns and disaster struck the
position the night takes check Queen
takes another defender removed and back
row checkmate okay so nada not a good
way for palm blaster to lose the game
all right we'll get on with the second
game here does anybody have any
questions about this game before we move
forward all right so let's take another
look at the beads games here and we'll
see see again how bad this Bishop can be
here all right so the beeps have white
again all right so far he's won a No
let's see if he can keep a streak up d4
black plays c6 okay so so now if you
were paying attention the last game what
should white
'we efore excellent all right if they
let you get a 4 and d4 in whether you're
playing white or black do it all right
so now you've got you've got nice
control of the whole center all right so
now black plays 6 Knight to f3 so even
if black plays d5 here okay we wouldn't
take here because then that would let
this Bishop become free all right we
could just play Knight to c3 or
something okay let him do the trading
all right but in this position he he
didn't play d5 he plays the move
d6 we bring out our Knight so so
sometimes when when my opponents are
playing really passive like this that's
when you want to play aggressive okay if
they're defending so much we want to be
attacking because if if we're both just
defending and not really trying to take
squares will nothing's really gonna get
a competent I might even try c-4 in this
position but that's just my personal
taste but Knight to c3 there's nothing
wrong with again all these pieces into
play okay both moves are good like
almost nothing can be bad for for white
in this position you know he could play
Bishop to d3 Knight c3 c4 pretty much
anything and now blacks finally like
well I need to play and and you'd never
want to waste time in the opening that
and N in end games because time is
crucial all right and and but you just
you're given a white free move spike by
playing D 6 D 5 so it's so good he plays
a 5 and so who would have thunk he's
gonna move another one of these pawns
again so c5 trying to break this open so
c5 you can probably just ignore that
move which it does alright because it's
protected twice and we played Bishop to
g5 so so we think we're
doing good here because we're attacking
his queen
now here's another piece of a
grandmaster advice for you whenever you
move a bishop what is no longer like
whenever you move your bishop here for
the first time what is no longer
protected be too so so if black was
really good
what do you think he would play in this
position Queen to b6 yeah yeah yeah so
now through an x-ray he's attacking d4
and he's attacking b2 and now we might
have some problems Knight a for not very
good because we get this check so what's
a move we can play in this position that
would save the night without moving the
night well okay but that would be moving
the knight c3 very good okay
so always look out for that when you
when you have that position okay but you
know we don't really want our Knights on
the edge of the board okay so so we
wouldn't do that so let's see if Queen
to b6 was played in this game it wasn't
so so you see there's a lot of games
when you play amateurs playing they can
really get away with a lot a lot of
stuff okay even though I mean this isn't
like a the worst move you know you're
okay Bishop to g5 I mean it's not like
the worst move but um but you just leave
your cell phone as a sec so always be
cognizant you know if you ever Ruby out
your Bishop your pawns will be under
attack all right so so he plays Bishop
to e7 all right Queen to d2 this time he
sees hey my bishops under attack so so a
vast improvement from last game and now
he's got two defenders so he's doing
okay math math is adding up so Bishop
takes
Queen takes but look at what he did by
doing all of these trades he voluntarily
removed all his defenders from d4 so he
takes advantage of a pawn takes d4 okay
so so now what is under attack the
knight who do you think we should move
the knight all right so so try to keep
it simple for you okay if if okay I'm
under attack my Knights are in attack I
should probably just move my knight okay
where would be a good play if we were
going to move our Knight where would be
a good place for this night to go b5
excellent because it attacks the pawn
okay and also threatens c7 check okay
you want to make your moves have as much
punch as possible okay it's a
dual-purpose moves threatens the fort
threatens the guy he can't defend full
whereas I'll just play back here and
just attack the pawn well that's not
good enough because I can I can protect
it okay so yeah this is goodnight to b5
and even though the knight is like in in
their opponent's territory there's no
Queen that can come down and check or
anything so we're doing just fine
so we that's what we're gonna play
Knight to b5 and then he'll have to play
like night to a6 or something and then
we can take our pawn back okay but
unfortunately he's like well I get a
check okay I see a check I'll play a
check okay that's I mean he's usually
pretty good to get a check but but look
now it prevents my night from going to
that great square alright so he he
decides he doesn't want his Knight to be
up in so he plays Bishop to d7 so now we
take Knight takes
and and now we get snack to be fivin but
but black didn't have to let him through
that he could have played his knight to
c6
heck he could have even take him back
with the King because look you're in an
end game anyway the Queen's are off the
board that would have been fine too but
but because Knight takes the summon he
lets he lets it happen so let's see if
he can play a good move here so it looks
like a good move rook to see a it looks
great no look I'm stopping the check I'm
gonna attack your pawn but it's not a
good move
so notice notice the tricky piece all
right the night remember that now the
Knights that you don't operate in that
line system that we were talking about
earlier however King light-square rook
light-square a knight that can hop to a
dark square fort all right so obviously
he'll play King to d8 here well
obviously there's no obvious moves we're
playing beginners all right obviously
King to d800 he didn't want to be king
to d8 that's funny cuz he gets double
for it
oh man but I don't think there's I don't
know if he can even get out of this
anyway so King to e7 I guess he can
Knight takes c8 check for free so that's
pretty good and so now he doesn't want
to get double forth so he plays King to
f8
all right King to f8 so so now if you
really want to be greedy right and you
want this other rook at least you want
to try for that other rook what move
would you play here to at least try to
get this other Rilke here
well you if you play Knight to f7
unfortunately black would take so we
need one more man attacking that F pawn
so if we play our Knight back to d6
right we can try try to get him all
right but but he's got ways out of it
with only one way Knight to h6 or we
could just take his other pawn and just
just going from there okay but
unfortunately white retreats Knight to
f3 no reason to really retreat here
because he's not under attack and he's
going for it for here so Knight to f3
so black plays Knight to h6 to protect
the pawn anyway so now he gets he gets
this guy Knight takes a 7 and now he's
on he's on a mission Knight to f5 so now
he's protecting the pawn but there's a
very easy way to remove this defender so
let's say we really really want this
pawn like we can't live without it but
those Knights Knights here push G for it
yeah excellent g4 and then he's got to
retreat again and now we can take the
pawn ok alright so Knight to f5 white
comes back the b5 Beginner's only
beginners only you're out of Europe all
right
King to e7 get his King going and so now
he takes Knight B takes d4 Knight
captures Knight captures and now he gets
B 5 okay so now black is playing a rook
down so it's gonna be very tough for him
to get any
thing going but we don't want to give up
we just want to try our best to to get
something some kind of counter play in
this position so so white castles here I
probably wouldn't recommend it but but
he because this King but I guess the
reason why is because now the night
won't have any kind of forts like white
got earlier but with the king out of the
the action is going to take a long time
for a white to win this game so rook the
c8 very good eine ein there white plays
a for Knight to c4 attacks the pawn and
now Knight to c4 c4 yes yes so now you
attacking the pawn here very good very
good very b3 Knight to a5 so so very
good so by playing before now you left
yourself a hole here Knight to c4 but I
don't think it really matters in this
position as long as you don't put your
rook on b1 and fall for the fort I think
you'll be okay and unfortunately in this
position be 495 oh he doesn't he doesn't
go back to the hole
he plays Knight to c6 so so this is
pretty easy when you're when you're up
material you got a trade got a trade
now you take c6 check does that make
sense rook takes c6 and now this this
should be a pretty pretty easy game to
get on with it at work after c1
King to d7 all we have to do now is rush
hour punt if we just keep shuffle our
looks back and forth and moving our King
back we'll never win so we need to force
these rooks off the board and get these
pawns up and we'll have an easy easy
victory so that's a good good idea for
our white here King to d7 b5 rip the c5
up to a 2 tank c7 c3 nothing wrong with
going slow here nothing wrong King to b6
rook a to C 2 but but this pawn well I
guess we can bring them up here now all
right so he's preparing that we're a - C
- so black stops brick to c4 very good
so now we're going back to a5 that's why
we really don't want our King Castle
over here he needs to be joining in all
the fun of up here King to a5 work 8 at
a2 and so now blacks like alright he's
sick of this he wants to get his own
passed pawn going v a2 b2 and now Oh
oh he must have done this alright so
King takes a four and rook to be four
check and now this should be it should
be good but you never know they're these
these kinetic as we've seen before
connected passed pawns against the rook
can be dangerous but but I think he'll
be all right
Rick the d2 takes b5 Rick the d5 check
came to a four rook takes e5 King to b3
up so now I mean white is up a rook here
but this is actually kind of scary
because this King because he Castle then
the endgame is so far out of play if he
can win this pawn it might be kind of
dangerous so what would we play as white
here
yeah I would just play some mad defense
here and then if he tries to get up here
I'm gonna try to try to get my King to
see one as fast as possible just try to
stop all this from happening but instead
he plays rook to e7 and now he lets
black have a passed pawn only one two
three squares away so so rook takes b7
King to d2 but luckily White has three
passed pawns of his own are three
potential op has bones so he takes here
c3 rook takes c200 there's only one way
for white to save the game here
rook the c7 yeah I guess he could try
the check but that would just prolong
everything so just just go here and then
he'll get a queen here let's just say
upside down Queen here and then just
take take and then what's the winning
move f4 very good bring out for it and
then there's no way he can stop you so
slow and then white wins all right very
good
I like it yeah well yeah yeah I mean
well I guess he didn't need this King
after all he could have just played King
h1 at any time and so it looks like we
have time for one more game so in this
game the beeps has black and he's
playing a guy on the ICC ranked 1400
okay
so white starts out very good
efore black plays d5 Knight f3 Knight to
c6 and now we get the worried Lopez
Bishop to b5 attacks the night it's
basically the same thing he's trying to
remove the defender of the the e pawn
black plays Knight to f6 and white
calmly just develops the Knight to c3 to
protect the pawn he doesn't want to go
into any shenanigans where he takes and
then takes the pawn so just and so now
black tries the same thing okay you know
fish up the b4 so now white says okay
he's had enough of all this so takes I'm
giving you double pawns so so now black
takes back with the D pawn so now if I
if anybody tries to take his pawn he can
come down coin the d4 and
Knight of three would be good very good
very good
but that wouldn't work in that variation
oh yeah all right right yeah all right
all right
I like all right so so bottom line is he
takes back that way
and so white just needs to protect the
pawn d3 can also probably protect it
with castling yeah Castle but d3 and
then you know I'm under attack with the
pawn and I'll protected ethers so now
another pin going on Bishop to g4 pins
the knight to the Queen so now Knight
can't take the pawn all right
so white besides I'm gonna get safe
castle but he still got the pin on so
now black captures again to give his
opponent double pawns
all right so who do you think's winning
in this position sure yeah
they both have double pawns but White
has a maybe he could put us broke on b1
and be active so now if you're black
here what do you think you should play
should we take that night the answer is
no we never want to capture pin pieces
we want to try to attack them
unfortunately nobody can really attack
him go castle that's what I would do in
this position it's just there's never a
bad time the castle all right so far
here in the egg it in the opening it's
probably double exclamation Park any
time because you know you've won a
castle so you might as well just get it
out of the way maybe now in that opening
all right so so black decides he's gonna
play c5 I guess he's gonna try to get
rid of his weakness
his double pawn weakness alright so
white sees that he can attack it so I'll
do that
Bishop to a3 and so now he just keeps
offering triple pawns for white really
take them really take the triple pawns
he's too smart for that because he says
it's a trick because if on takes oh and
I can come down alright so he sees it so
Queen to e2 Queen to d7 so now he might
Castle long but that might be dangerous
cuz this B file is open all right cool
so now he's like I've taken the triple
bonds it's free so so let's ask somebody
would you rather have triple pawns and B
be up upon or not have triple pawns and
be even yeah good answer
yeah so now you got more pawns than them
but but they're gonna be really tough to
hold on to so let's see so he does it
Castle castle castle alright so let's
see so Queen to e3 so so good move got
himself out of the pin and threatening
to take and get the checkmate so black
decides I'll attack everything to finish
up the pond so you really want to try to
begin the most out of all your moves
like white he got a lot out of last move
you know out of the pen attack and now
with this Queen so if you can do more
than one thing when you make it moves
you're doing something all right so now
he's like I'll take it because he sees
after
Queen takes a three which he does why
did he just give him this bishop for
nothing yeah possibly
wait wait what so so the answer to joins
question was no Knight takes f7 okay 4x
the rooks and now rook H to e8 so he
wants want them to take this one which
it does King takes d8 and so now he
really wants to check him on d1 just cuz
it's cool but it but he sees this darn
bishop over here so he's like get out of
here f3 Bishop to e6 and now we all see
what's coming once again though he
chooses the wrong rook to check with all
right possibly you might want that rook
on b1 but he's gonna check him with this
one rook to check King to c8 all right I
will I want that rook on b1 though all
right so we got to try to get an attack
going c5 Queen takes a - that's a
blunder so even though black just start
oh I want a pawn
not good did everybody see what white
should do to get a pawn back rook to a-1
this is a move you would slam - because
he thought he was doing so good getting
that pawn but little did he know nope
in tasty too so now we have a choice who
to take with I know who I would take oh
you can't even take with the Queen
well if you could pay with the Queen I
would definitely take with the Queen
well you can't queen or so Brooke takes
a seven so we're doing really good here
us well I don't want get into that okay
so c6 so now let's try to checkmate him
somehow a black okay we say blacks that
really in a position to checkmate except
all right so can we checkmate him so
let's see how he goes about checkmate
so he sees a check so that's the great
way to start if you can't see any kind
of checks like hopefully well we'll just
try check alright so they placed King to
c7 so now did we see another check but
we can take a look right sometimes
sometimes we just want to try a
checkmate though well that's the
question that has to but that's why
help yep
so sometimes we just so work takes is
good but sometimes sometimes there's
better right so Queen to f4 check and
unfortunately black can only go one spot
because they can't escape because of the
pawns so when it plays King 2d 700 he
protected his rook but it's not really
uh-oh so can anybody see a good check
for white that might end up in checkmate
so work the d1 one because then we would
almost get checkmated so there we have
any other checks Queen to d6 and
unfortunately that's how the Beeb's goes
down to d6
checkmate but so so the downfall for
black black was doing pretty good until
he got too greedy and took that pawn and
then with the rook a1 smashing move got
the pawn got the check that eventually
the mate so so watch out watch out for
that if they can get the you're a pawn
right back you might not want to go too
far and take those pawns and remember we
don't want open lines in front of our
castle King we want these kind of lines
okay well great thank you all for coming
stay tuned we have a very special Grand
Master to do analyze this so hopefully
you guys I'll stick around for that and
thank you
toward the beads for bringing in his
games